hey reject nation I'm Greg elbow I'm
John over at our patreon we do TV show
reactions from many shows including
awaken of kione's and what about supper
war two different video you request we
must definitely cover and put up on
YouTube and occasionally that opens up
the door to aspiring filmmakers who want
us to check out their short films and
today comes from a person named fund me
edit Ola fund me Productions is their
channel and this person we're all doing
in Canada mainly does fan films and
brick films
I want to check out their short film
because supposedly it won first place at
the fanboy Film Festival 2016 so this
should be good but let us decide I don't
care what award you get what matters is
our opinion can't be bought by prestige
yeah man right Gone with the Wind
overrated
Susan came to make a better movie my
sleep Schindler's List whatever he's so
taken now and he made ready player well
let's do this
oh yeah this short film is called
independent interesting it's an
independent short film comedy let's do
it
[Music]
like that bumper hi
I'm Finn let's get to know each other
whoa you can't speak so really get to
know me so I might be a film director
yeah I know right like you know it's
kind of unrealistic this was in this
generation I mean the build film
director guy joined a whole buncha guild
you got to start with Lopez your job
security I mean it's not like Canada's
Got Talent exactly an option you know my
parents you know they're they're pretty
okay with it as long as I don't like
smoke weed which is like their one rule
but my friends who are a bunch of
feature road leaders and doctors who are
a lot more critical Andrew
Sarah okay the classes boring don't
interest me but the film industry you'd
have a better shot at making porn
actually make porn
I'm thank you I was people thank you
okay poorness kress is no craft there
well the new ones are an HD not a bad
story oh hey guys I just searched up
porn actors make a hundred thousand a
year Wow
120 grand how am I still trying to work
I want be direct or not before most
STD's
but I don't want you to someone who
chases their dreams and then powder me
fail
as much as I hate to admit it Sarah had
a point her words were you stuck with me
until second period
[Music]
sharpening paper was the perfect
opportunity how much it was almost too
good to be true
this has to be [ __ ] and it was tiny
tip seriousness this film festivals
[Laughter]
percy alleline
action film though no romantic rejection
moves a breeze right the sword in there
when I finish my cable to my sister
Marceline check for spelling mistakes
but I mostly gives to her what she was
done I develop it's for my investors we
just have kilometers is gonna cost my
mr. walnuts of logistics $5 goodbye
that was are you ah look everyone in
this family wants a piece of my mind
I guess what porridge I should get to
have a say on how its elite spent on I
don't I can't imagine somebody just
coming with all these furloughs
that's 500 the last if a friend allows
my money you forgot my birthday this
years they're conveniently so make up
for it on what you're gonna use this
money to do what exactly are you gonna
spend $500 on pizza no I say no you're
gonna use it to buy more comics I love
to read Asterix and Obelix the greater
feeling in my question
Oh Marvel superheroes whichever new ones
that they're crazy enough food oh no no
I forget it's adventurous of thinking
$500 my in might be a real parrot
no oh you're gonna use it to buy new
glasses since you destroyed the one I
bought last year
yeah got that even shipping it all right
you don't know you're shameless lobby I
use the money to buy costumes and props
and any money I have looked over it will
be used as in the movie the film
festivals props and costumes look at
mister your school already have given
you $1,000 equipment to make this film
in business and
I know that the Sun in my face right now
the controlling $20 to buy costume bra
pains and whatever else you need for
this movie of yours stuff myself to help
the drama department is the answer to my
problem
they had a whole bunch of stuff I keep
using makeup for the place was costumes
and most importantly actors psyche as my
friends Andrew
Simon and Peter Peter was in my last bit
darker times which was terrible so in
order to convince him to be this new one
I have to blackmail me with this poster
[Music]
game the Phillip women in school is even
easier once I Sunday technology loan
agreement I was good to go nothing could
go wrong until it did I can't really
describe what happened but rest assured
it's not something that you want to see
[Music]
but I just don't care did you even read
the script I just can't take someone
seriously who wears that tape on their
glasses yeah I got it I was in oversized
watch that doesn't fit hey what the hell
what's wrong with you start shooting my
movie today and it sucked not the app is
memorizing lines so news is they have to
scrap it fine I guess fine I guess did
you actually direct them or just give
them the script and flip
as eroded it the second one yeah I'm not
surprised
rubber dark intentions yeah I remember
intentions less real be born like your
movies have to actually tell them what
to do you don't want to think about it
and new blogs came in today thank God he
looks like a little bunch of black Harry
Potter of all that tape does that Lucy
is my own once the director ran out of
money
oh you guys are early we thought we
could make an effort today yeah we were
kind of [ __ ] earlier no guys I'm
sorry we didn't even apologize no no no
I'm sorry
look this is my first time doing this
all right I I don't really know how to
work with people I usually just do those
animations Legos like it's not to being
your leader but if you give me a second
shot I think I can change that
Oh correct so this is the cenotes the
break-up you you know you're in trouble
because you kissed your girlfriend's
sister so you're gonna be crying you are
going to be his best friend n supports
you just to kill on camera penetrating
love scene two to1 dizzy penetrating
[Music]
oh there's a cute babe in this movie so
you can't hate it dude I thought I was
so charming that was I thought that was
incredibly charming I feel like this
whole thing is intentionally supposed to
be shot the way it is I mean right from
the very beginning when he has that
insert of like you know the bad fit and
his friends with bad voice dubbing I
haven't seen your other films so I'm
going to assume that this is all
intentional and that's how I definitely
interpret it I like those low firearms
when it's intentional that it's supposed
to be low fie and that's part of the
charm behind it where you got like bad
audio offbeat direction yeah
like poor quality because this whole
story of you trying to put together a
short film no one's cooperating and
you're talking about your passwords are
not good and no-one's supporting you so
it only makes sense that this would be
intentional and that this is all
supposed to be shot in a way that feels
like you didn't have money to put this
something so adorable about the way this
is all being done there are times I'm
like is this intentional either way I
was still able to roll see I'm gonna
really enjoy it yeah and I think there's
something that like just having made so
many weird little shorts in school and
outside you know just on our own time
and stuff like any time it's about
trying to put a short together or film
together that always like really
resonates just like a fun journey to go
on each time and I love how it's about
just trying to put together a short film
I see a lot of stories about what the
hell should we write a script about or
you're trying to put together a feature
film you just trying to put together a
short film your friends are not
cooperating with you like these are real
life struggles and then to see it
balancing with this the way it's shot
has its charm because you allude to
other films of like and I did this one
it was terrible and it has a brief
because worse quality than the one for
watching
yeah there was some really funny stuff
no moment with your parents man oh man
does have to be your real parents like
yeah I imagine you probably let them
improvise your mom just seems so funny
they're just like put your parents in
everywhere if you're one of your film
dad you feel like they just have a cameo
at least because they're really funny to
watch I don't know if you listen like I
said yeah yeah I was gonna say like do
you guys have you know sort of an
artistic family of sorts because like
they've just both looked so comfortable
on screen and sometimes you know like
I've seen a lot of shorts and I've even
done some where people put their family
and people put their parents in and
sometimes really awkward but I thought
this is actually really charming and
really fun to watch well it looked like
your mom was having a lot of fun and
your dad I don't get the impression that
they are the artistic types it looks
like fun Me's probably gone down the
path of something a lot more artistic
and the filmmaker for you and this bit
is probably riffing off of that
real-life variants you know but at the
same time like it still came across
really yeah this lo-fi movie about a
dude having to learn how to put together
short film how to direct actors and then
having this like character art learning
how to be a director no I'm sorry don't
apologize but at the end of it I'm like
I want to see a scene at least a scene
from this short film you're putting
together I thought we were gonna get
that so I was like oh man I thought we
were gonna get an actual scene from it
that was gonna be like really bad is it
a porno yeah but I had a lot of fun
watching this dude congrats on the
success you have with this short film
and thank you so much for sharing this
with us this is adorable you include
your whole family in here yeah oh yeah
well I gotta imagine like I almost
wonder if that's where you go to school
or you know friends of yours from school
because it definitely had the earmarks
of like you know we're in video
production that was the whole charm of
it all is that when you take a step back
and realize how intentional this is it
becomes this like very charming short
film this made me like miss the days of
being in my high school theater
productions like college video
production it was fun to put together
where it feels like an old-school
homemade video short film yeah yeah
you're trying stuff out and getting shot
yeah it's like trying to assemble
anything at all Congrats man yeah well
done happy for you this was a little
blast guys go check out the fund-me
productions channel there's a link in
the description box or it
show us some lovin I want to check out
some of your you know your brickfilms
and you reference it here you know like
the lego shorts that you do and
everything like that
Rick flicks so I decided to check it out
thanks bud
much love to you